à vos marques
il y a parfois des signes qui ne
trompent pas les sensations inexplicable
de plénitude
car oui aujourd'hui je vais écrire une
nouvelle page de mon histoire
je suis franklin et bagues et j'avais
gagné cette course faire les minima et
me qualifier pour les jeux olympiques
laissez-passer l'artiste on
m on sait pas que
c'est moins sûr
au départ qu'on va faire regardant ça va
on est tous là pour l'amour du sport ok
allez on s'y remet des gardes à tout
coup droit n'a pas su engager vous êtes
disqualifié pour faux départ c'est un
gars sympathique pas le temps de marquer
pour le moment là on est là pour l'amour
puisque les gars 1
je vous demande de quitter la piste mais
regard avec la gonfler pas on est tous à
faire alors l'a fait alors le starter
san avons saisi franklin telle our là
c'est pas capable de respecter les
règles respectivement les athlètes et
public